Wollen wir noch eine Minute warten?
Guten Tag.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Azak.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarchitekt.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch hören.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Okay, danke.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Miriam Rega.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Miriam schreibt sich M-I-R-I-A-M und Rega schreibt sich R-A-E-G-E-R.
Rega.
Frau Rega, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt und ich bin geboren am 6. April 1981.
Entschuldigung, sind Sie 45 Jahre alt?
45 Jahre, ja.
Ich bin 1981 geboren.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,72 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
65 Kilo.
Okay.
Frau Rega, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Seit einigen Wochen bin ich sehr müde.
Ich bin schnell erschöpft.
Ich habe Sehstörungen.
Und ganz klar, Moment.
Der muss an.
Ich habe auch Gangunsicherheit.
Ich kann nicht gut gehen.
Ich bin sehr unsicher beim Gehen.
Ich habe kein gutes Gefühl im linken Unterschenkel.
Da kribbelt es sehr und ist so ein pelziges Gefühl, ein taubes Gefühl.
Ja, es geht mir nicht gut.
Könnten Sie Ihre Sehstörungen genau beschreiben?
Was haben Sie?
Ich sehe Doppelbilder.
Also nebeneinander sehe ich häufig Doppelbilder.
Außerdem haben Sie unter Unterschenkel linkseitige Taubheitsgefühl?
Ja, besonders links.
Im rechten auch etwas, aber links viel mehr.
Auf dem linken Unterschenkel an der Seite habe ich Taubheitsgefühl.
Und es kribbelt und es ist so pelzig wie eine Ameise, wenn eine Ameise über die Haut läuft.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Frau Rege, sind diese Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Langsam.
Oder gab es einen Auslöser?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Mein Partner hat gesagt, wir waren wandern vor einigen Wochen und da hatte ich einen Zeckenstich am Bauch.
Wir haben die Zecke entfernt und ich habe das beobachtet, da war aber nichts auffälliges.
Das war vor acht Wochen knapp oder sieben Wochen war das.
Aber ich habe keine andere Erklärung, ich weiß nicht.
Diese Ereignis vor acht Wochen.
Vor acht Wochen, eine Zecke.
Hatten Sie Unfälle, Verletzungen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich bin zwar in den letzten Tagen mehrfach beim Gehen gestolpert, weil ich nicht so sicher gehe.
Aber ich habe mich dabei nicht verletzt.
Entschuldigung, ich habe Ihren letzten Satz nicht verstanden.
Ich bin in den letzten Tagen häufiger beim Gehen gefallen, weil ich unsicher bin.
Aber ich habe mir keine Verletzungen zugezogen.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie in Laufe der Zeit einen anderen Arzt aufgesucht?
Nein, bis jetzt noch nicht.
Ich würde eigentlich dann jetzt zu meiner Hausärztin gehen, nächste Woche.
Aber jetzt ist es seit gestern noch mal schlechter geworden.
Und dann habe ich mir gesagt, jetzt gehe ich hier in das Krankenhaus und lasse mich untersuchen.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen, Frau Reiger.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, ich muss regelmäßig Medikamente einnehmen für meinen Darm, weil ich eine chronische Darmentzündung habe.
Und ich muss auch Medikamente einnehmen für meine Schilddrüse.
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Aber ich habe jetzt, nein, ich frage jetzt nach Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Da habe ich keine Medikamente genommen, nein, keine besonderen.
Haben Sie in Laufe der Zeit Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter an Ihrer Haut Veränderungen?
Hautveränderungen habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Leiden Sie unter Fieber, Schüttelfluss, Nachschweiß?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Bewegungseinschränkungen?
Nein, so direkte Bewegungseinschränkungen habe ich so nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, mein Gefühl im Unterschenkel, besonders links, ist nicht so gut.
Und beim Gehen spüre ich eine Unsicherheit.
Also das hat sich schon verschlechtert.
Insgesamt mein Gehen, meine Bewegung.
Haben Sie in betroffenen Bereichen Schwellungen oder Rötung oder offene Wunde bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Leiden Sie unter Überallkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Ja, manchmal ist mir schon etwas schwindelig, das kenne ich sonst nicht.
Aber nicht immer.
Aber manchmal ist das so, besonders wenn ich diese Doppelbilder sehe, beim Sehen.
Haben Sie in irgendwelchen Körperteilen Schmerzen gehabt?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Hirsten oder Atemnot?
Nein, nein.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Der Appetit ist normalerweise ganz gut.
Aber in den letzten Tagen, als ich so müde und schlapp war,
war der Appetit nicht ganz so gut.
Frau Rege, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben diese Beschwerden seit ein paar Wochen.
Können Sie uns eine bestimmte Zeitraum, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ich schätze mal so seit vier Wochen.
Sie haben keine Fieber?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich kann ganz gut schlafen.
Sehr gut.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr zehn Jahren eine chronische Dammentzündung.
Ich glaube, die heißt Colitis ulcerosa.
Und dann habe ich eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Das sei so eine chronische Schilddrüsenentzündung.
Auch seit ungefähr dieser Zeit ist das bekannt.
Und da muss ich auch ein Medikament für nehmen.
Ja, das sind die beiden Erkrankungen, die ich habe.
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht verstanden.
Seit wann haben Sie Schilddrüsenunterfunktion?
Auch seit zehn Jahren.
Ja, okay.
Und dann sind Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich wurde im Alter von zehn Jahren als Kind am Blinddarm operiert.
Und vor jetzt 15 Jahren hatte ich einen Sportunfall.
Da war mein Oberarm, mein rechter Oberarm, gebrochen.
Hier direkt am Oberarmkopf hieß es damals.
Und das musste operiert werden.
Noch etwas?
Nein, sonst keine Operation.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme einmal für die Schilddrüse ein Jod Tyrox.
Jod Tyrox heißt das.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette Morgens.
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Dahinter steht 75.
Okay.
Und Mesalazin.
Mesalazin heißt das.
Dahinter steht 500.
Und da nehme ich Morgens zwei und Abends zwei.
Ich habe das notiert.
Und da nehme ich noch Schaum, so cortisonhaltigen Schaum und Zäpfchen.
Das ist Budess. Budesschaum heißt das.
Und auch Budesszäpfchen nehme ich.
Zurzeit aber weniger, weil im Augenblick ist das mit dem Stuhlgang ganz gut.
Der ist kaum blutig.
Wie oft wenden Sie Budesszäpfchen an?
Ja, vielleicht viermal die Woche, pro Woche.
Zurzeit.
Sie haben gesagt Schaum.
Ja, dieses Budess gibt es auch als Schaum.
Und das nehme ich auch an den Aftar.
Rektal.
Schaum, was bedeutet Schaum? Ich habe es nicht verstanden.
Schaum ist wie wenn man sich Haare wäscht.
Schampo, wie ein Schaum in den Haaren.
Das ist ein Schaum, der auch in den Aftar eingeführt wird.
Das ist Budesschaum.
Budesszäpfchen ist anders?
Zäpfchen ist anders.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Habe ich nicht.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Sehr gut, ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke vielleicht ein oder zwei Glas Wein pro Woche.
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie früher geraucht haben?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Nommen Sie die bitte.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Sehr gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist 71 Jahre alt.
Er hat hohen Blutdruck.
Worauf er besonders achten muss,
ist, er hat eine an der Hauptschlagader im Körper.
Die Bauchschlagader hat eine Erweiterung, eine Aussackung.
Deswegen muss ein Blutdruck immer genau kontrolliert eingestellt sein.
Man überlegt noch, ob er daran operiert werden muss.
Das ist aber noch nicht entschieden.
An dieser Aussackung.
Die Bauchschlagader ist wie ein Ballon.
Ja, ich weiß.
Die Mutter ist 69 Jahre alt.
Vor 4 Jahren hatte die Mutter Eierstockkrebs.
Das wurde operiert und auch noch bestrahlt.
Aber es geht ihr ganz gut.
Sie hatte vor 15 Jahren eine Operation an der linken Hüfte.
Bekamen Sie ein neues Hüftgelenk wegen Arthrose.
Sie sprechen über Ihre Mutter.
Ja, Mutter.
Hüftegelenk, Arthrose, okay.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester, die ist 43 Jahre alt.
Die ist gesund.
Ich habe richtig verstanden.
Ihre Eltern sind 11.
Ja, die Eltern leben noch.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich lebe mit meinem Partner zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich bin Busfahrerin.
Frau Reiger, haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Die Arbeit als Busfahrerin ist schon stressig.
Im Straßenverkehr.
Aber ich kann mich immer wieder ganz gut davon erholen.
Ich kann Ihnen erinnern, Sie haben recht.
Sie kontaktieren mit vielen Leuten.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, ich war in den letzten Monaten nicht im Ausland.
Nein.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin, glaube ich, vollständig geimpft.
Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Da sorgt immer meine Hausärztin und der Betriebsarzt.
Da muss ich regelmäßig hin zur Untersuchung.
Da werden alle notwendigen Impfungen veranlasst.
Das ist sehr wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Früher habe ich das gemacht, aber seit einigen Jahren nicht mehr.
Ist Ihre Monatsblutung regelmäßig?
Oder haben Sie Probleme bei der Monatsblutung?
Die Monatsblutung ist immer etwas unregelmäßig.
Die Frauenärztin sagt,
das hängt mit der Colitis ulcerosa zusammen.
Und mit den Medikamenten.
Die ist nicht immer regelmäßig.
Zwischen 4 und 6 Wochen.
Haben Sie dagegen Medikamente dahin?
Nein, nicht.
Ich komme damit zurecht.
Ich gehe regelmäßig zur Frauenärztin zur Untersuchung.
Sie sagt, im Augenblick muss man da nicht unbedingt etwas behandeln.
Ich habe das notiert, Frau Rega.
Ja, ich habe meine wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas uns zufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Mir fällt noch ein.
Seit ungefähr 2 Wochen ist mir aufgefallen,
dass ich meinen Urin nicht mehr richtig halten kann.
Beim Wasserlassen habe ich den Eindruck,
dass ich das nicht beenden kann.
Da kommt immer Urin hinterher.
Das ist seit 2 Wochen.
Seit 2 Wochen?
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht verstanden.
Dann können Sie wiederholen bitte.
Wenn ich auf Toilette gehe, Wasser lasse,
kann ich das nicht stoppen, richtig.
Sondern es kommt immer noch Urin hinterher.
Es tropft hinterher.
Der Verschlussmechanismus ist nicht mehr richtig.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas gemacht?
Bis jetzt noch nicht.
Ich wollte nächste Woche zu meiner Hausärztin gehen.
Aber bis jetzt nicht.
Ich hatte Urlaub jetzt noch einige Zeit.
So könnte ich gar nicht arbeiten können als Busfahrerin.
Das ist eine schwierige Situation.
Sie haben recht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ich habe im Augenblick 3-5 Mal pro Tag Stuhlgang.
Das ist aber für mich nichts Besonderes
wegen der Bedammeentzündung.
Aber das ist im Augenblick ganz gut,
weil es kein Blut hat.
Zurzeit habe ich keine blutigen Stühle.
Das ist für mich relativ normal.
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Blut im Urin bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Wie gesagt,
ich habe meine wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas anderes?
Nein, im Augenblick fällt mir nichts anderes ein.
Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit,
sich vorzubereiten.
Ich habe die Patienten-Sprache
möglichst in medizinische Fachbegriffe.
Die anderen Kollegen, die zugehört und zugeschaut haben,
haben vielleicht noch Ergänzungs- oder Verständnisfragen.
Dann bitte ich Sie jetzt zu stellen.
Frau Reiger, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, bitte.
Leiden Sie auch eine Gedenknisstörung
und auch Konzentrationsstörung?
Also nicht.
Aber in den letzten Wochen,
wo ich mich so müde und erschöpft gefühlt habe,
habe ich auch schlechtere Konzentration.
Herzrasen und Herzstuppen?
Nein, das nicht.
Wenn es keine weiteren Fragen gibt,
lasse ich Sie einige Minuten in Ruhe.
Ich melde mich gleich wieder.
Herr Kollege, wie sieht es aus?
Ja, ich kann anfangen.
Ja, bitte.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen
und möchte Sie Ihnen vorstellen.
Hatten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Danke.
Unsere Patientin heißt Miriam Reiger.
Sie ist 45 Jahre alt,
1,72 Meter groß.
Sie wiegt 65 kg.
Frau Reiger stellte sich heute
aufgrund seit vier Wochen
bestehender,
persistierender,
langsam aufgetretener
Fatigue und Diplopie
bei uns vor.
Nach Angaben
der Patientin
leidet sie
außerdem unter
linken Schenkel
Hypothesie und Parasthesie.
Linker Unterschenkel.
Außerdem teilt die
Patientin mit,
dass sie
vor acht Wochen
von einem Säck
gestoßen wurde.
Von einem Säck.
Ja, ein Säck.
Sie gab
an, dass sie
unter
unsicher Gehen
leidet.
Gangunsicherheit.
Deswegen
ist sie
häufig gefallen.
Okay.
Trotzdem habe sie
keine Verletzungen.
Gut.
Außerdem berichtete die
Patientin über
die Verletzungen.
Seit zwei Wochen.
Die Vegetative-Anäse
ist unauffällig bis auf
Inappetenz.
Die Fragen
Verletzungen, Unfälle,
Bewusstsein, Verlust wurden
verneint.
Die Anleitung der Patienten
war in den letzten Jahren
an Colitis ulcerosa
und an Hypotriose.
Bei der Patientin
wurde im Alter von 10 Jahren
eine Appendiktomie durchgeführt.
Außerdem
wurde bei der Patientin
nach einem Sportunfall
wegen
rechtseitiger
Humerusfraktur
eine Operation durchgeführt.
In diesem Falle Humerus-Kopffraktur.
Sie sagte, das war
im Bereich des Kopfes, Oberarm-Kopfes
Humerus-Kopffraktur.
Das ist eine Abwirkung.
Deswegen muss man da
manchmal operieren.
Nicht immer.
Die Patientin hat diese Information.
Die Patientin hat gesagt,
es war der Oberarm am Kopf gebrochen.
Dann sagen wir,
wie Sie sagten,
es war der Oberarm am Kopf.
Das waren die Operationen.
Besonders der Medikation
nimmt sie
Iotrox 75 Mikrogramm
einmal täglich.
Pertozolosin 500 Milligramm.
Zweimal morgens,
zweimal abends.
Außerdem
wenden
die Patientin
Budesang und Budesepsung
viermal pro Woche an.
Zurzeit, ja.
Sie hat berichtet,
wenn es schlimmer ist mit der Colitis ulcerosa,
dann wird sie
das nicht täglich machen.
Aber zurzeit viermal.
Im Augenblick ist das relativ stabil.
Nicht regelmäßig, ja.
Bei der Patientin
sind keine Allergien
oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Sie ist nicht Raucherin.
Er trinkt,
ein bis zwei Gläser Wein
pro Woche.
Drogenkonsum wurden fern.
Sein Vater
leidet an ...
Ihr Vater.
Ihr Vater leidet an
Hautanävrisma.
Ihre Mutter leidet ...
Ihr Vater hat aber noch eine Erkrankung.
Noch eine chronische Erkrankung.
Der Vater hat noch hohen Blutdruck.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ihr Vater leidet an Arteriehypertonie.
Und an einem, wie Sie sagten,
Bauchaortenanorisma.
Ein Anorisma der Bauchaorter.
Das ist das Anorisma.
Wie die Patientin wohl geschildert hat,
das wird zurzeit regelmäßig beobachtet
mit Ultraschall.
Zurzeit operiert man das nicht.
Aber es kann sein,
dass er daran operiert werden muss.
Können wir sagen,
für Anorisma
ist eine chronische Erkrankung?
Das ist im Augenblick
eine chronische Erkrankung.
Er hat das wahrscheinlich schon mehrere Jahre.
Das ist erst entdeckt worden.
Das ist ein Bauchaortenanorisma.
Das wird im Augenblick
konservativ behandelt.
Ohne Operation.
Ihre Mutter leidet an Ovarialcarcinom.
Deswegen wurde bei ihr
eine Operation durchgeführt.
Nach Operationen.
Wie alt ist die Mutter?
Und wann war das Ovarialcarcinom?
Zurzeit ist sie 69 Jahre alt.
Aber im Alter von 60 Jahren.
Im Alter von 50 Jahren.
Das war vor 4 Jahren.
Vor 4 Jahren.
Im Alter von 65 Jahren.
Vor 4 Jahren wurde die Diagnose
Ovarialcarcinom gestellt.
Es wurde eine Operation durchgeführt.
Und was wurde noch gemacht?
Eine Bestrahlung.
Postoperativ.
Oder eine Radiation.
Und was hatte die Mutter noch?
Bei der Mutter
wurde im Alter von 50 Jahren
eine Luftgerenkarthrose.
Eine Luftgerenkarthrose.
Und dann wurde sie operiert.
Die Mutter wurde vor 15 Jahren
an einer Kokzarthrose operiert.
Und man bekommt meistens
eine künstliche Hüfte.
Eine Tepp.
Total Endoprothese der Hüfte.
Ist meistens die Therapie.
Wegen Kokzarthrose.
Gut. Hat die Patientin Geschwister?
Ja, die Patientin hat eine Schwester.
Meine Schwester.
Sie ist gesund.
Sie ist gesund?
Ja.
Jetzt frage ich Sie, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtsdiagnose
oder die anämnistischen Angaben
deuten am besten auf eine Neuroborreliose.
Eine Neuroborreliose.
Neuroborreliose.
Was damit differenzial diagnostisch in Betracht?
Als differential Diagnosen
kommen eine Hemktumore.
Oder eine Multipsiklerose.
Ja.
Encephalomyelitis.
Encephalomyelitis, Multiple Sklerose.
Wenn die Patientin
in der Anamnese nicht
erwähnt hätte.
Wäre wahrscheinlich
der erste Verdacht auf eine Encephalomyelitis gefallen.
Dafür sprechen die Visus-Störungen,
die Doppelbilder, die Diplopie,
die Parästhesien am besonders linken Unterschenkel,
die Gangunsicherheit,
die Urininkontinenz.
Das sind, denke ich,
die Symptome, die auf eine systemische Erkrankung hinweisen.
Meinen Sie Encephalomyelitis?
Die andere Namen.
Encephalomyelitis Disseminata
ist der Begriff.
In Deutschland sagen viele Leute auch Multiple Sklerose.
Ja, Multiple Sklerose.
MS abgekürzt.
Aber meistens ist es doch die Encephalomyelitis Disseminata.
Was würden Sie jetzt diagnostisch vorschlagen?
Sollte sich meine Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen,
würde ich zunächst
bei der Patientin
die Vitalparameter kontrollieren
und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
würde ich eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann würde ich die Physik
und eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Okay.
Und jetzt nach der körperlichen Untersuchung,
die ja ganz wichtig ist,
was würden Sie eventuell an apparativer Diagnostik machen?
Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen eine Fachprüfung.
Aber ich würde auf alle Fälle...
Sie müssen ja einmal die Sache
mit der Neuroborreliose ausfüllen.
Okay, das kann sein.
Aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch
die Encephalomyelitis müssen Sie
ausschließen oder diagnostizieren.
Was bietet sich da an?
Ja, zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich eine...
Liköruntersuchung.
Likvor ist sicherlich auch sinnvoll.
Aber heutzutage, glaube ich,
ist der Goldstandart ein MRT.
Magnetresonanztomographie.
Weil im MRT können Sie sehr gut
sogenannte Entmarkungsherde sehen.
Im Bereich des Rückenmarkes.
Also ein MRT des Schädels und der Wirbelsäule
würde ich machen,
um das Rückenmark darzustellen.
Das ist, glaube ich,
der Goldstandart der Untersuchung
in der Encephalomyelitis-Diagnostik.
Likvor-Punktion.
Sicherlich auch ein Bein.
Das war früher sicherlich viel wichtiger.
Aber heute mit MRT, glaube ich,
ist das MRT heute ein Goldstandart.
Das man versuchen sollte,
dass man das MRT zur Verfügung hat.
Das hat ja nicht jede Klinik sofort.
Dann ist das sehr einfach.
Die Labordiagnostik ist sicherlich wichtig.
Was bezüglich der Borrelien-Symptomatik...
Diese Dinge muss man parallel laufen lassen.
Aber ich denke, wichtig ist,
dass Sie an beide Dinge denken.
Dass Sie beides auch in Ihre Diagnostik
und in Ihrem Rückenmark planen.
Vom Alter her kann das durchaus
für eine Encephalomyelitis sprechen.
Es gibt viele Menschen,
die in diesem Lebensabschnitt
zum ersten Mal an einer MS erkranken.
Und ja, man muss gucken.
Erst mal vielen Dank.
Das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Sie haben das sehr ruhig gemacht, systematisch.
Sie können die ganz wesentlichen Fachbegriffe kennen.
Im Nachhinein noch mal...
Sie hatten, glaube ich,
nicht genau gefragt
nach Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen.
Das habe ich als Patientin geholfen.
Mir ist aufgefallen,
dass ich nicht das Wasser richtig halten kann.
Ich würde das möglichst auch gerade,
was die Colitis angeht, noch mal fragen,
wie oft Sie zurzeit Stuhlgang haben.
Und natürlich auch,
haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen
bezüglich der Miksion.
Das ist schon natürlich eine wichtige diagnostische,
anamnestische Angabe, dass die Patientin sagt,
ich kann auch nicht mehr gut meinen Urin halten.
Haben Sie bald einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, ich habe...
lange seit September.
30. September.
Ah, 30. September.
Welchen Fachgebiet haben Sie bisher gearbeitet?
Allgemeinmedizin.
Ja, gut.
Die Allgemeinmedizin ist wichtig.
Ich glaube, in Deutschland auch.
Alles gut.
Dann erst mal Danke.
Wir können gerne nächste Woche
uns wieder Donnerstag verabreden.
18 Uhr.
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen erst mal einen schönen Abend noch.
Bis nächste Woche.
Tschüss.